how's it going guys we're back here with
archer engine just working on this game
engine over the month and i'm going to
just let you guys know what updates have
happened here's the main branch it's
still the same for the last month and i
don't think i'm going to merge in my
work this month well because it's pretty
far from finished as i will show you
so uh i've decided to re-do refactor the
whole thing and do a component
like structure so we're now going to
have a lot of public components that you
can kind of piece in and i'm still
working on how all that works but it
should be a lot better than before
before it was basically
you know it was an interface with a lot
of spaghetti and sure it worked fine if
you follow the directions but now it
should work a little better
because uh well i guess the main setup
is we're gonna have
you know just some core
settings for the engine kind of like
your main
like your main settings and we're going
to have all those and we're going to
have levels or maps so essentially
you'll set up your settings and knit the
engine
and then
start loading maps and these maps are
basically just going to be a bunch of
components of certain source and these
components will work together in special
ways some of them some components can
have components underneath them others
cannot
they're more like others are more like
leafs and some of them need to work
together specifically like there's a
mesh renderer and a mesh and you need
both
to
to work because the mesh renderer is
going to be responsible for doing the
actual rendering so this is also going
to allow for a better snap-in of
different graphics types as we're going
to now have a graphics interface and i'm
going to implement different types
opengl there's going to be vulcan
directx as well but as you can see it's
a big work in progress and i've spent
most of the time just thinking about how
to restructure it what components do how
the components work
and
yeah there's still a lot left to do
before it actually runs and does what
you would hope it would do
so that's why there's not going to be
any
pushes to github other than the branch
i'm working on but no main update and
when we finally do get to an update we
are going to be on version three yeah
we're jumping from two to three because
well
the three is so much different than two
it's not even going to be similar
there's no reason to increment the the
smaller part
so yeah version three already
so i have a lot to do basically there's
i still gotta sort out the libraries i'm
slowly piecing them in one by one i'm
trying to get it in a nice structure
that's maintainable and that's really
about it there's not a whole lot else
for me to say right now i guess i'll say
is whatever comes to mind as i flip
through these files and we'll call it a
video i don't want to keep you guys too
long because there's not really a ton to
take away i don't think other than hey
i'm rewriting and here's where it's at
and
yeah the uh i i'm working on windows so
i still have to test linux once all this
works but i think it'll be okay
i'm also going with the latest version
of c plus plus i can we're going with 20
if we can we might even try 23 if we
need any of those features but we're
moving a little past 17 now i think it's
time
i am able to reuse a lot of my old code
like i really liked how my window worked
previously
with uh glfw i don't see a
main reason to change that i already had
a lot of code
set up to do specific stuff and i'm just
re putting it back in here and i'm
changing it as i go so a lot of the ways
i had things coupled and the old version
i didn't really like i didn't think was
very great for maintainability so i'm
trying to keep things
a little more
contained we'll say for what they do
and i'm still working on that going
forward if you want to see the branch
that i'm actually working on i think the
one i last pushed to was this one called
right i don't know why i called it that
it's just i couldn't think of a better
thing to say it's just like yep where
this is what we're going with is
actually a little far behind but if you
want to follow what's going on this will
probably be the branch unless you see a
new branch pop up
that will be getting pushed to here and
there and of course you're always
welcome to contribute if you want to pop
in here and hack around if not if you
just want to support the project give
this video a like and maybe give the
repo a like as well that's all i got for
you guys today let me know if you have
any questions down below i hope you
enjoy the video i hope you'll enjoy this
new version
of the engine when it comes out or of
the library rather when it comes out i'm
really looking forward to it for next
month i'm planning on having a tech demo
up
along with this so
once i get most of this working and most
of the things back to functional how
they used to be except with this new
setup and on these components i'm hoping
to also have a few examples including a
a
demo level that we load up with some
controls and stuff kind of like we used
to do with the old versions but
also hopefully i get this editor going i
have some ideas for making an editor
uh of this of this library functionality
basically a front end where you can drag
and drop because another thing
and the last thing i'll mention before i
cut this off is i'm working on a save
system so previously there was no save
system your save was essentially your
code you would have you know you would
have a big uh main block of code and
you run it it loads up all your stuff
there was no other save other than that
that was that was it you just you know
you have your code that loads things as
you have them written if you want to
modify you can but now we want to do
something a little different i want the
ability to basically serialize levels or
serialize how you have all your
components
set up that i'm not sure if i'm going to
get that by next month
but that's the goal we want to have
something like that that way the whole
point of that is you should be able to
have a third party
thing
basically run this engine build stuff
and then save out how you have it built
that is the goal
with uh the saving i still got to think
about how to do that i don't really know
the best way i have some base ideas
um they some just seem too janky like i
could get it done by just dumping the
text files and then parsing a text file
but i don't know if i really want to do
that that's going to get messy and i
think there's going to be a cleaner way
to do it let me know if you got any
thoughts on that as well all right i
appreciate i appreciate you guys for
watching appreciate all the support that
you guys show um people on patreon
the youtube members all that stuff it
does mean a lot for me going forward
and i'll see the next one peace out